>> AND THE KYRIE SITUATION.
WE ARE TALKING TO ADAM SILVER
ABOUT THAT.
AND THE 76ers ARE SUSPENDING BEN
SIMMONS.
>> AND ONE THING, HE WILL BE IN
A MUCH BETTER ATTITUDE BY
THURSDAY.
>> SO, HERE IS THE SITUATION.
AND HERE IS THE VIDEO FROM
YESTERDAY, AND MONDAY AT
PRACTICE WITH THE SIXERS AND HE
DID MORE THAN STANDING THERE.
>> ACCORDING TO WHO?
>> HEY, HEY.
>> AND HERE WE GO HERE, AND AT
THE END OF THE WORKOUT, AND HE
IS LIKE KIND OF DRIBBLING THE
BALL BEHIND THE TEAM AS THEY
GATHER AND PUT THE HANDS IN.
>> NOTHING WRONG THERE, AND WE
DON'T KNOW WHAT HAPPENED.
>> HE HAD A CELL PHONE IN THE
POCKET.
AND WHEN THE COACH IS TALKING --
>> A LITTLE DISENGAGED THERE,
KENNY.
>> I COULD POINT OUT SOMEBODY
ELSE IN THAT VIDEO.
>> AND SO ANYWAY, HE --
>> LOOKING AT EDDIE GREEN THERE.
>> AND THEY ARE NOT TALKING TO
DOC RIVERS OR LISTENING TO DOC
ANYMORE, AND IT IS WORSE TODAY,
BECAUSE HE WAS KICKED OUT OF
PRACTICE BY DOC RIVERS WHEN HE
REFUSED TO TAKE PART IN THE
DRILL, AND DOC SAID, ENOUGH, GET
OUT.
>> WELL, BY FRIDAY, THEY PLAY
FRIDAY, AND SO --
>> HE IS NOT GOING TO NEW
ORLEANS TO PLAY IN THE OPENER,
AND YOUARE LAUGHING AT THIS
POINT.
>> IT IS STUPID AND SILLY AND IT
IS EVERYBODY'S FAULT.
BEN SIMMONS DESERVES THE BLAME,
BECAUSE WHEN, YO, EVERYBODY ASKS
YOU HAVE TO BE A BETTER
BASKETBALL PLAYER AND THEY ARE
PAYING YOU $35 OR $40 MILLION,
THAT IS A FAIR THING.
AND THE SIXERS DESERVE THE
BLAME, BECAUSE THEY HAVE NOT
IMPROVED AN FIRED ONE COACH, AND
THREW BRETT BROWN UNDER THE BUS,
AND DOC RIVERS AND YOU GUYS WANT
ME TO TAKE BEN SIMMONS OUT OF
THE GAME.
YEAH, WE DO IF HE IS GOING TO
STAND AROUND AND NOT SHOOT THE
BALL, YES.
WE DO.
THE NUMBER ONE BLAME IS WITH BEN
SIMMONS.
KENNY, SHAQ, YOUR COACH, YOUR
MOM AND DAD, YOU SHOULD WANT TO
BE A BETTER BASKETBALL PLAYER,
BECAUSE THAT IS YOUR PROFESSION.
THAT IS YOUR JOB.
YOUR COA